[Musique]
bonjour frais michel terrot bonjour
monsieur viol temps bonjour aux
auditeurs de martinique 1ère président
en martinique du parti des républicains
nous sommes à moins de 15 jours du
premier tour des législatives
comment ressentez vous les choses fred
michel terrot en sept ans est quasi
veille du scrutin
mais on sent que et pas beaucoup de
mouvements que la campagne on aurait dit
que la campagne un peu peu un peu morte
en martinique
simplement ce en martinique et dans
l'hexagone aussi c'est vrai que
malheureusement un élections
législatives intéresse un peu moins ce
que les élections présidentielles parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'affaires aux élections
municipales aussi mais c'est l'occasion
pour les candidats en tout cas pour nos
candidats de rappeler l'importance du
député à l'instant il y avait un
reportage sur vos antennes qui a
expliqué le rôle du député qui est de
voter la loi de contrôler l'action du
gouvernement mais également de les
interdire pour fera des choses très
localement par exemple ici en amazigh
mais c'est oui on peut les faire aussi
pour la martinique
beaucoup de candidats parlent du
problème d'indivision qui gangrène les
familles puis qui qui bloquaient des
milliers de logements qui bloquent des
milliers d'hectares de terrain et c'est
un problème que les députés ou les
futurs députés devront prendre à bras le
corps je note que en corse
récemment le 6 mars dernier une loi sur
l'indivision a fait cesser les désordres
foncier comme ils l'ont appelé et cette
loi ou aient pu être élargi à la menthe
unix ou non si nos députés avait par
exemple demandé par un amendement qu'ils
soient étendus donc c'est possible par
la loi
pour peu que nos députés prennent à bras
le corps cette mission qui est une
mission essentielle pour faire avancer
la martinique et faire avancer
globalement le pays vous vous dites que
cette campagne semble peu molle
peut-être parce que les jeux semblent
faits récents sondages hier pour rtl le
figaro est elle si estime que la
république en marche le mouvement d'
emmanuel macron obtiendrait entre 320 et
350 députés à l'assemblée nationale et
que votre parti serait le deuxième
groupe avec entre 140 et 150 5 sièges
devra porter à lens est difficile de
faire des sondages sur 577
circonscriptions ce n'est pas
une élection comme une élection
présidentielle on peut sonder l'ensemble
des électeurs du pays facilement là il y
à 577 circonscriptions donc 777
élections différentes
ce que la guadeloupe va voter n'est pas
ce que la 4e circonscription de fort de
france va voter ou la troisième
circonscription de la cua l'immédiat
rien à voir avec emmanuel mâcon n'est
pas le nier la dhuys ont été contestés
que quelque chose est en train de se
produire
oui cela va de soi il y à une
effondrement du parti socialiste il y à
un maintien quand même des républicains
autour de 20 à 23% donc le socle est
encore là et puis un renforcement s'ils
font national donc il n'y a plus de
forces comme avant la droite et la
gauche comment on connaissait
traditionnellement mais quatre force 4
force un nouveau parti en marche les
républicains mélenchon il son groupe de
la france est soumise et puis le front
national donc il faut compter donc sur
quatre
quatre grands partis maintenant et non
plus deux donc il ya de la phase
nouvelle
la nouvelle configuration de l'assemblée
nationale mais personne ne la connaît
aujourd'hui
ce qui est certain c'est que de notre
côté les républicains nous ferons tout
pour être dans la majorité donc remporté
ces élections
ouais et voilà c'est avec d'accord qu
emmanuel macron non seulement réussi son
coup avec la présidentielle les
premières les premiers les premiers
jours de son mandat de président qui ne
s'est pas planté à ce jour oui et non
oui pour la syntaxe et résidentiel de
séduire oui et non oui pour la stature
présidentielle pour ce déplacement à
l'étranger
maintenant pour les premiers les
premières lois qu'il veut faire voter
notamment les lois sur la moralisation
de la vie publique vous avez vu que l'un
de ses ministres monsieur ferrand et est
enferré justement de tout le monde de
court mais pour l'affaiblir la manière
dont on veut moraliser la vie politique
il faut d'abord justement avoir un
comportement et vous savez que
maintenant les éducateurs sont et sont
extrêmement exigeants compte donc autant
vivante ministre sur des rumeurs parce
qu'il n'y a rien d'illégal à ce moment
nous parlons sur ce qui a été fait mais
la suspicion ans rennes malheureusement
aujourd'hui peut-être trop souvent
la condamnation est en leur pouvoir en
mairie du synthé scream simple rumeur
suffit pas vous rappeler que pour un
candidat aux présidentielles on avait
déplacé le parquet financier pour un
costume c'était du privé on avait
déplacé le candidat aux présidentielles
on avait bousculé parce qu'ils avaient
reçu costume de ses amis c'est de
l'argent privé
il avait fait embaucher sa femme ce
journal qui était qui était de l'argent
privé qui était de l'argent privé et
même pour cette raison l'argent privé
qui n'avait rien à voir avec la gestion
de fonds publics eh bien le parquet
financier s'était déplacée parce que on
estimait qu'il y avait là un risque un
risque de prise illégale d'intérêt et
que de toute manière même si
juridiquement c'est est contestable
c'était de toute manière moralement
condamnable et il suffit que il y à une
soupçon de condamnation morale pour que
effectivement ça puisse nuire à l'action
politique et à l'action politique tout
entière pas seulement en marche pas
seulement où l air mais à toute la
politique en général
alors il ya une recomposition du paysage
politique au plan national on doit
apprendre à faire avec contre est forcée
mais on n'a pas le choix de toute
manière il ya une volonté de la part des
électeurs de dire qu'il faut arrêter de
faire la politique comme on avait
l'habitude de le faire c'est-à-dire
s'opposer systématiquement comme on le
voyait au parlement et notre chef de
file monsieur françois baroin l'a dit
très clairement nous ferons de la
politique différemment nous nous
battrons pour être dans la majorité
mais si par extraordinaire nous sommes
nous étions dans l'opposition nous
serions dans l'opposition constructive
c'est à dire que nous voterions les lois
qui nous semble être utile pour
l'avancée de la société et puis nous
nous opposerons à celles qui nous
semblent qui nous semblent hostiles
vous êtes chef de parti politique ici en
martinique
martinez qui réagit toujours avec un
temps de réaction n'est toujours agi
plus quelque chose par rapport à ce qui
se fait à paris vous avez l'impression
que ce mouvement en marche prend en
martinique
et cela au détriment des républicains je
ne le pense pas honnêtement puisque
dans les élections martinique l'équation
personnelle du candidat est très forte
ce n'est pas parce qu'on met une
étiquette sur un candidat qu'il va
forcément gagner les élections
lorsqu'elles seront faciles tous ceux
qui cassent pas facile tous ceux qui ont
pris le large en martinique
non non ce serait trop facile c'est
comme si on disait que le ppm soutenait
le candidat amont à fort-de-france
carrément une sortie quatrième donc le
ppm va perdre les élections
nécessairement sera quatrième aux
élections législatives ce serait un
raccourci à ne pas commettre
jusque l'équation personnelle du
candidat est très forte au côté bien
entendu de l'idéologie du parti
politique qui est derrière ce candidat
mais l'équation personnelle la manière
de fonctionner le comportement du
candidat est aussi très important et
essentiel de nouveau dans nos
départements dans nos régions comment
appréciez-vous tous mouvements autour
dans marche ici en martinique
moi c'est une mode alors certains
prennent le train en marche justement au
parti exercer plus de l'autisme c'est
plus de l'opportuniste quand vous
regardez ce qui qui sont ce mouvement
ils ont milité dans plusieurs mouvements
avant l'état doit visiter à gauche on va
pas revenir dessus
ce qui m'intéresse c'est que nos
candidats nous avons des candidats nous
avons des candidats que nous soutenons
tout cas qui nous ont demandé
l'investiture et leur soutien nous
allons les soutenir et j'appelle tous
nos militants tous nos sympathisants à
être derrière nous nos candidats qui ont
eu un programme complet qui ont une
éthique qui ont un comportement aussi
sur le terrain des gens qu'on connaît
c'est pas des gens qui ont été débarqués
ou qui ont été parachutés c'est pas des
gens sur lesquels on a causé une
étiquette donc j'invite nos militants et
nos sympathisants à venir
les trois candidats qui ont sollicité
notre soutien à savoir karine rousseau
et miguel laventure et sylvia 7 soutane
dans le sud est puis celui qui fait
bande à part yan monplaisir également
alors lui il a choisi de ne pas demander
de soutien des républicains partie de la
famille de la durée de sortie de la
famille doit t il
il a une stratégie qui lui est propre et
nous respectons cette stratégie question
très ça quelles sont les chances de
chacun d'entre eux sont très fortes
elles sont très fortes puisque vous
allez nous avons eues mais nous avons
des retours sur le terrain qui laisse
penser que rien n'est joué
contrairement à vos sondages que vous
avez donné qu'ils sont valables pour
l'hexagone
mais ici c'est la mobilisation de chacun
qui va faire la différence
et cette mobilisation et de la campagne
et labeyrie tôt c'est ce qu'ils vont
réussir à se mobiliser le plus qui vont
gagner l'élection tout simplement parce
que parce que entre 30 et 35% en général
des électeurs se déplacent aux élections
législatives c'est nettement insuffisant
mais ce et les partis qui réussiront et
une autre famille politique que se bat
justement pour mobiliser les électeurs
pour faire en sorte que nous avons
longtemps en tête de cette élection les
sortants du souci à se faire avec les
candidats soutenus par les républicains
ici à martin mais ça c'est clair c'est
que c'est pas un peu de la méthode coué
là pas du tout pas du tout si vous êtes
sur le terrain monsieur viol tôt vous
verrez que s'il ya cette soudaine dans
le sud remplies de plus en plus de
salles convainc de plus en plus de
personnes c'est la méthode karine
mousseau sur le terrain aussi c'est une
candidate qui a démontré ses capacités à
faire campagne qui a démontré aussi sa
loyauté sur le terrain puis miguel
laventure c'est quelqu'un qu'on ne
présente plus qui a lui aussi démontré
sa force de travail et on en a besoin
pour pour être député à l'assemblée
nationale partiellement quelqu'un qui
parle si vous voulez mais quelqu'un qui
sait étudier des dossiers et je crois
que c'est ce qui nous manque
a la martinique des gens le dossier
parce que la loi c c'est quelque chose
d'écrit on est trop souvent dans le
verbal dans l'oralité à la martinique et
on oublie souvent écouté oui on fait
beaucoup de bruit beaucoup de parlotte
beaucoup de verbiage inutile et on
oublie qu un député doit avant tout
travailler les lois c'est vraiment un
travail sur le terrain mais beaucoup
dans les dossiers dans les projets et
puis dans les ministères pour faire
avancer et c'est important aussi d'avoir
des députés ici de grandes familles
politiques comme la nôtre parce qu'on
est tout seul à 5000 nationaux groupe de
15 comme c'est le cas de nous trois
députés actuels qui sont dans des petits
groupes des coupes de 15 ça ne passe pas
par miss à 77 députés vous n'avez pas de
force quand vous arrive à l'assemblée
nationale et que vous avez
vous avez 15 15 députés donc en voyons
il ya des unités qui sont notre groupe
de 152 900 de 250 merci fred michel
terrot rappel vous êtes président des
républicains arsenic bonne journée bonne
journée à vous
[Musique]